bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti e solo
video li ama un caso io sono felice oggi
siamo di nuovo con il mio e con il mio
gruppo di amici e sono riuscito a far
apprendere impostore che let's go sto
mangiando un pancotto li posso mangiare
un punk o jolie senza abbassarmi a
mascherino come va bene allora io c'è
scateno 2 brothers allora ammazzo subito
leo in defense and via ragazzi ho
ammazzato leo da due ore e ancora non
c'è il cadavere o che aspetta tutto
perfetto iphone perotti c'erano o che
hanno formato e morto le telecamere
stavo stavo guardando visto già anche
faceva un task io non sono sicuro di
nichi ma quello che sta dicendo giusto
perché era con me ed è andato a lei
reski piano io non ho non abbastanza
informazioni
mi spiace avanti per pietro a casa che
noia va eliminata sempre giudizi la
partita anche se sei fiume e che noi a
quilmes la devi ammazzare anche noi
perché dà fastidio se sei impostore chi
ammazza
se sei un clooney ti ammazza uguale
perché ti fa votare quindi che noia è un
fastidio
cioè a prescindere ma ho trovato eco
morto in security in questo preciso
momento è morto anche mickey allora sono
molto posso dire la tua strano che non
ti uccide ce l'ha con te affabile oltre
i security ero completamente perché
stavo arrivando al pannello c'erano
quattro persone in security team
sì eravamo noi inseguire avanti prenderò
io credo che io io io ragazzi vi giuro
che ho fatto il corridoio di sopra sono
andato in security ho visto il corto
riportato non posso dire che ci credo
non lo so perché io ci credo
non ho provato ciardi io mi fido di
quello che dici ma sai perché ma sai
perché è troppo minuto volte mi sembra
troppo chi è lorenzo
no secondo me un grande chi hai votato
dice a roma e ho badato charlie io voto
charlie perché l'unico posto dove è
stato prima non ero io non sono cioè io
stavo facendo però più vari fiumi fahim
pentire di aver votato charlie volevo da
rete
scusami pro vota chi vuoi vota chi ti
pare brother
no io sono un po sospetto su martina
perché se la sta giocando particolare
lorenzo a calmarsi barcellona non farci
incolpa chario dico forse stimate lavori
anche il ragionamento è rubando una cosa
che era già la modella
la rega bravi gatto siamo in emergency
meeting pretendiamo che non sono io
perdete se votate me no non perdete non
perdete non è vero che possiamo parlare
possiamo parlare tutti che sono marci
accusa charlie io voto istantaneamente
per charlie perché voi avete detto che
in security c'era un'altra persona
charlie era il security esatto cioè
quello che pesa è il mio ragionamento
kent kv j paj già e marche questo è il
mio ragionamento punto mai credi quello
che va però io penso a farci dovevo dato
istante mio metodo ces che però ragazzi
6 mar si fosse mai come se fosse a
martino è fatto una partita della vita
mai però né quelli non posso dire solo
che martina quando gli postare
ammazzatutti quando e chi no però come
ha fatto io prima non ho votato nessuno
perché mai state votando charlie e io
non so perché charlie era con me in amin
però non so neanche chi altro può dare e
c per me così vado dice perché ma sono i
ora vediamo quello che succede tanto e
marge che fa vediamo vediamo
[Musica]
e l'altro il palermo ha posto alla
famosa ok prove abbiamo in totale maggio
ragazzi allora io ho finito le tasche da
due ore ma non è tanto clamore a kimi si
sono chiuse due volte le porte lavorai
oppure meglio con me dentro arci non era
mai league ma cosa che stavo aspettando
inter e per ad vincerà martina l'altra
parte no io non ho marci e ho trovato a
un certo punto era bloccato con meno
elettrica che non ha fatto nulla
mi sono messo in un angolo che parliamo
io io stavo cercando di marty marty
secondo me
non la sento di potermi fidare di gianni
marsi purtroppo neppure io io io io e la
mia più grande soddisfazione in questo
gioco vedere quando la gente ha torto
lo dice lo dice a posto nascite ma che 4
possiamo aspettare una cifra forse
possiamo aspettare un'altra achille ti
do la possibilità di giocare ancora un
po favi sei contento perché in qualche
minuto in più di 22.000 raga ok e se
prendo reactor è fatta è fatto è fatto è
fatto è fatto e fatta è fatta picks live
set ecco qualcuno è fatta ragazzi se
questo qualcuno è fatta dai ragazzi di
parigi bercy ma volta imparata giocarla
per me
qualsiasi cosa ha detto veramente per
giocare ragazzi per me non vanno dalla
mia vita voglio il cazzo finale però te
lo giuro i rovino tutto grazia che te
l'abbiamo lasciata via medina
[Musica]
il problema qual è il problema è che non
mi fido di nessuno specialmente
quest'uomo qua dove noi non c'è più era
pietro non mi fido di lui perché ogni
volta che lui in porta ogni volta che
gioco è lui che mi ammazza perché ce
l'ha con me quel maledetto fix chiamo le
luci ai pixel
charlie mi è passata vicino forse non è
lei scherza charlie è la classica
persona che quando che non si discolpa
mai non uccidendo t forse lo farà io
stavo in ossigeno fatto la pasta quella
che divismo da lei è l'ossigeno e va
bene ok poi stavo scendendo salito a è
salito da scudi si ok in questa vision
land stato ci stavo andando a fare il
ekdal vede fatto fissato le luci stavo
tornando su perché c'è una vasca
navigation e vedo incontro buddy che
però mezzo mezzo me voleva uscire
secondo me continua a salire e paolo il
cadavere sopra dove stanno le armi e lui
veniva da lì che noi a decidere
il navigation convinto del tutto questo
però le volte la stai tirando sai che se
non è lui è un problema
ok però se non è lui e allora ecco gli
altri anche passò di lì allora sono io
l'assassino ma non è prossimo a voi
siete voi che siete degli stati verso di
me
a me dispiace un sacco veramente però
sono tutti così convinti che non lo so
ora che io me ne vado basta dai dati ha
votato nessuno prova che mi dicono che
sono stato io ma è presente ma mi
sbagliavo
non c'è o no
ma il time il akron dell'euro la cole
delle o meno male novak e non ci avrei
non avrei mai azzeccato una parte il
resto è ossigeno ma fa niente
ormai sono in reactor pro vedere la
security allora ragazzi io security non
la guardo mai spesso perché non c'è
nessuno che noia che passa di liberi
cesca tensione che noia in caffetteria
allora vediamo di riuscire a capire se
l'economia quest'amara tusk che odio di
più in assoluto del fastidio ho anche
sbagliato o mio dio laives qua il
prossimo aggiornamento non la voglio più
vedere stata scanu la voglio più vedere
orribile sapete che non ho la più
pallida idea di chi fosse potrebbe
essere semplicemente che noia che sta
giocando bene oppure march che si è
fatto si è nascosto parecchio bene
secondo me non è niki comunque segni chi
veramente incredibile se la sta giocando
benissimo 16 fidatevi di chi se la sta
giocando di una bambina cattiva farmina
cattiva baby cesca si scappa dai
cadaveri senza riportarli sentiti che
noia che noia che noia
vista la vista
la cantante non ce la faccio da sky mi
ripeto da schio nove ragazzi per sera
non gas di oggi spero che vi sia
piaciuto mi son divertito come sempre un
sacco iscrive al canale lasciato un bel
commento qua sotto vento che tal molto
avuto fuori va dall altro episodio di un
gatto perché vi faccio uscire molto
spesso di fare mi piace un sacco non
smette di piacermi belle ragazze
[Musica]